now traditionally newspaper reporters
were held to the highest standards of
Journalism you'd wake up in the morning
throw on a robe snatch The Washington
Post off the driveway and settle into
your breakfast snook with a cup of
coffee
if you read an article in the Washington
Post you assumed it was true just listen
to Walter Cronkite
the old principles of print journalism
it's good journalism it's it's honesty
fairness
truth and uh and totality of the story
telling both sides of a controversial
story all of those things should be
practiced in every story that is carried
on the air newsrooms used to be filled
with Scrappy middle class guys chasing
Scoops with a pen and paper today's
newsrooms they're staffed with insecure
social climbers from Northeast liberal
arts colleges the culture has been
captured by academic snobs and American
intelligence reporters are just infantry
for an ideology they wage corporate
terrorism against their enemies seeking
to bankrupt whoever editor tells them to
do just this weekend CBS News pressured
Apple CEO Tim Cook to pull advertising
from Twitter
should Apple continue to advertise on
Twitter
it's something that we ask ourselves
generally my view is Twitter's an
important property I like the concept
that it's there for discourse and there
is a town square there's also some
things about it I don't like there's
discourse and then there's
anti-Semitism
it's abhorrent just point blank that
there is no place for it so is this
something you're constantly evaluating
or it's something we constantly ask
ourselves
persuasion's dead we agree to disagree
that's dead today if you disagree with
the wrong people you're to be destroyed
first punch is your character second
punch your bank account and when you're
in the crosshairs of a journalistic
assassination attempt it's terrifying
Dave Portnoy the president and founder
of Barstool Sports not his first rodeo
he's been attacked for decades but he
never thought he'd be attacked for
helping Mom and Pop pizza places survive
the pandemic portno has been doing Pizza
reviews all over the country and raising
50 million dollars for small business
it's free publicity
it was an assembly line of pictures over
there all right we're at the Lorenzo's
Robbinsville New Jersey police have been
telling us we had to get to look at that
the tomatoes really out in top and
blinging right there I was getting
nervous Frankie because they were taking
so many pictures it's like the pizzas
cooking in that box and we all know
what's the number one enemy of a pizza
spending too much time in this box this
thing's not even thinking of flopping
one bite here we go
very crunchy very firm very good this
thing has bite it has pop it has spunk
it has pizzazz
then Dave had an idea the one bite Pizza
Fest this Saturday in Coney Island he's
bringing together over 35 pizza joints
from around the nation to Showcase their
best pies sponsors and advertisers help
produce the event
but the Washington Post couldn't
tolerate a pizza party for charity
food reporter Emily Hill whose latest
articles include the pumpkin spice latte
just turned 20. this is how we got here
and Chick-fil-A's pimento cheese chicken
sandwich is a detour worth taking
decided I'm going to toss a hand grenade
into a pizza party screw small business
food reporter Emily emailed all of Dave
portnoy's sponsors here's one of her
emails quote we are planning to write
about the festival and how some of the
sponsors have drawn criticism by seeming
to associate themselves with Dave
Portnoy who has a history of
misogynistic comments and other
problematic Behavior
and when Dave found out he did what she
didn't do he called her
we have this pizza Fest happening on
Saturday and you're reaching out to our
advertisers and you're basically sending
an email that says to the effect Dave's
a misogenic racist no I'm not
well I I can I can read
if you want
if you want I can read what you actually
sent I have it we are planning to write
about the festival and how and how some
of the sponsors and participants have
drawn criticism by seemingly to
associate themselves with Dave Portnoy
who has a history of misogenic comments
and other problematic Behavior
you said you didn't do it then I have
the exact evidence of you doing it so I
didn't say
well no
a liar with an agenda which is funny
because she's a food critic usually she
writes about how food tastes but this
had nothing to do with pizza she's cold
calling sponsors telling them Dave's the
devil and they should pull out a pizza
Fest
why would you include that in the in the
email to sponsors
them you know sometimes you have to say
something like
like no it's sort of a reporting tactic
when you want someone to respond you
kind of have to indicate that there
might be something negative and then you
get them to engage that's all I was
trying to do I really wanted them to
engage with me that is a sad state of
Journalism if that's a tactic so Emily
the heel lied got caught and then
claimed lying was a reporting tactic
that's like a reporter emailing a
business saying hey your store's on fire
call me back
and why are reporters inciting ad
boycotts no one else cares who's
sponsoring the pizza party so why does
the Washington Post
and why does the Washington Post want to
do damage to hard-working Pizza people
because they hate Dave Portnoy that much
if this is all about Dave Portnoy then
why don't they just go talk to Dave
Portnoy
when were you going to reach out we were
planning tomorrow morning
so you're going to write the article and
then give me like I've had that a bunch
people write a full article and then
give me the points after you know we're
doing a bunch of reporting and we wanted
to make sure that when we finally did
talk to you we could really
kind of present what you know or talk
about things more fully based on like
what like it sounds like you have your
opinion Made To Me based on that email
this sense like something who's gonna
hit me last second be like comments and
all this negative stuff no this is like
this is kind of standard journalistic
stuff like unfortunately yes
uh Dave you're evil we're going to print
in five minutes any comment that's
journalism today it's happened to me
dozens of times almost every reporter
writing about Fox pulls the same stunt
they're just checking a box so then they
can call the assassination journalism
the time to talk tomorrow would that be
okay like I
think I've got all my questions ready
and stuff to talk to you about would
that be okay can we set up a time
I want to see the article before you do
it
you know it's not really we can't do
that why can't you do why can't you do
that because all I do when I is I
validate all the stuff you're about to
make up against me Washington Post which
is uh wildly left leaning publication
you have things you've said you hate
Trump you hate Elon not that I'm those
people to think you're gonna give me a
fair Shake I wasn't born yesterday
so why wasn't Emily ready to talk to
Dave if the story was set to publish in
24 hours she didn't have questions ready
well it's because she was never planning
on talking to Dave reporters don't want
to talk to targets
when they can just drone strike them
without emotion looking someone in the
eye when you stick the knife in makes
you feel dirty you have to shower
afterwards and guess what Emily canceled
the morning interview
but because Dave recorded the exchange
and has a powerful platform the world
can see the truth
Barstool Sports founder Dave Portnoy
joins me now so Dave again I'm sorry
it's a Willis Reed situation thoughts
and prayers I'm just doing the best I
can with the glasses today uh why do you
think the Washington Post hates you so
much
it you know I I the only thing I come up
with is in this era ever since Trump
came on the scene I feel like people's
brains just got broken
um the the Washington Post is widely
left leading a left-leaning organization
like the New York Times Like Business
Insider uh it's the same group it's like
unfortunately uh I know whether I'm
going to be talked about positively or
negatively just by the name of the
organization that I'm about to read if
it's Fox I know it's probably going to
be good if I know it's uh you know the
Washington Post is going to be bad and
that is a sad State on both aisles to be
honest
um you kind of can predict what's going
to happen before it happens so because
what you associated with Trump or you
interviewed Trump they think you're a
trump guy and they want to take you down
yeah I think that they view me well
there's a couple things the connection
to Trump there is a general Barstool
Sports for sure as a Vibe of like bro
culture fratty white privileged male we
span everybody but that is I guess what
pops into people's mind and those people
are hated by The Washington Post the New
York Times and we're seeing kind of as a
symbol of that so that that entitled
person right now is somebody who is
despised by the left and we are a
Forefront blaring me personally signal
for that for the people who hate that
culture so you're right but it's gotten
to a crazy new level where they don't
just want to disagree with you or resent
you because your bro your Friday
whatever they want to destroy your
entire Enterprise They want to destroy
the people you're giving money to
charity to they want to take down your
sponsors they want all your employees
fired what brought that from here to
here
you know I think journalism has become
activism really uh they're not looking
for the truth the ironic thing and you
alluded to it for this pizza Festival
like the very people who are now trying
to threaten these pizzerias and be like
you were going to write a hit piece and
Associate you with this bad person they
are all fighting to shut these people
down two years ago they didn't want them
open I'm the one who was fighting to
keep them open raise money keep small
business and then they turn around to
these very people that we're trying to
help save and say you shouldn't do
business with them it really they have
become activists there's not an ounce of
Journalism I watched the Walter Cronkite
piece that you played in the beginning
of this segment there's no interest in
telling both sides of the story ever I
have been the subject of so many hit
pieces and I have started so many times
cordially let me tell my side of the
story your facts are off if anybody with
an open mind who hasn't made their
judgment who listens to both sides is
gonna be you know what this guy is not
who are portraying them to be no one has
ever that's the only time that phone
call that I had to record that's the
only time I've ever talked to who has
written a hit piece about me it's crazy
but that is the state of Journalism
um you know I grew up in an ERA with my
dad like if I wasn't a media I don't
know that know any differently the New
York Times is garbage The Washington
Post is garbage they are activists
they're not journalists they have no
interest in the truth none well you know
because you were successful without them
so that drives them crazy have you ever
spoken to someone that's written a hit
piece about you at all that was the
first time
that's the first time I have like I said
I have an exchange that I the New York
Times spent a year writing a hit piece
on me I uh Emily Steele was the author's
name I reached out to her probably 10 to
15 times begging for a sit down I knew
she was going through my Instagram
profile contacting every acquaintance
people I knew didn't know I said I will
tell you anything you want to know I am
an open building
too much of an open book Dave that's the
problem so you have steel and then you
have the heel is the heel invited the
pizza Fest because she is a foodie
yeah listen I here's the problem they
don't want to meet me because I'm not a
Despicable and horrible as like you said
you don't want to see the person you're
right and that's why they don't by the
way and then they can plead ignorance be
like I didn't know this I didn't if you
interview me and you start getting facts
you may not be able to put pen to paper
because you know you're being a jerk and
dishonest they lie to themselves yeah
she's invited what do I care she can
come yeah but you know it's not only
that they might learn facts they might
actually like you Dave
and that's what they're afraid they
actually don't like you they don't want
to like you they don't want to know you
they just want to hit you from a
thousand yards in the sky and then go on
to the next Target all right well tell
us a little bit about if people want to
go to the event in Coney Island how do
they do that
yeah so there's a couple tickets left
we're trying to avoid this tropical
storm but it's the best pizza in the
country
it is we're getting a hammer with rain
it's gonna be 35 pizzas the best the far
a lucali uh you name it we have the best
Brooklyn square pizza 200 bucks all you
can eat sounds expensive it's not
Sally's Pepes if your pizza you have to
be there and maybe who knows Emily heal
maybe you'll have a slice of pizza and
she can confess her sins to me all right
she can do a review you guys will patch
it up Dave thanks so much
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else